some travel days though those continue
around the country covet related
staffing shortages and then those
weather issues causing problems for many
airports there as we take that live
picture
at reed international joe mohler joining
us live from the airport with what it
looks like now hi joe
the holiday travel nightmare continues
for thousands of people across the
country at the last check at the website
here at the airport the airport there's
about a dozen cancellations so far today
but there could be more cancellations in
the near future because another storm is
heading our way well christmas was on
saturday but the cancellation started
adding up on sunday and then on monday
but some of these cancellations are now
lingering today there were another six
thousand delays tsa screened just over 2
million travelers on thursday december
23rd airlines like alaska airlines blame
weather in the pacific northwest and
united airlines blame staffing issues
our very own kirsten joyce visited a
family in seattle over the weekend and
she's been trying to get home she has
been trying to find a flight for about
two days now she has been documenting
her travel experience online it looks
like a headache we caught up with lisa
crave here at the airport who had a
tough time getting back here to vegas
from seattle today
i called and was on hold for five hours
i was on hold to wait to chat with
someone for over an hour
i changed my flight twice
[Music]
all right uh the best bet if you are
traveling is to check the status of your
flight beforehand and give yourself
plenty of time if you are heading to the
airport and prepare for possible
cancellations we do have that other
storm that nate just mentioned heading
this way we also have new year's eve
this weekend on friday and new year's
day on saturday so it's going to be very
busy at airports across the country joe
muller reporting at reed international
airport live local now